ich glaube dass das theater einen großen
magen hat wie es ein großes gehirn hat
das theater ist so ich oder ich halte es
für so unverwüstlich
das ist die unterschiedlichsten
möglichkeiten in sich sozusagen verdient
aufnehmen kann und sie wieder ausspucken
kann ein wesentlicher großer teil des
theaters wie ich es mir vorstelle ist in
der tat das literarische theater mein
herz ist aber durchaus offen auch für
andere formen des theaters ich bin auch
keiner von denen wie die zeitung für die
ich mich gerade äußere es in den letzten
jahren und möglicherweise darüber hinaus
doch immer wieder geradezu vehement
fordert dass man doch die roman
bearbeitung und die autorisierten filme
reduzieren möge ich finde das nicht ein
guter theater abend ist ein guter
theaterabend ist ein guter theater abend
woraus er sich irgendwann mal gespeist
hat und woraus er entstanden ist ist mir
erst mal wurscht
guten abend und herzlich willkommen hier
aus den bnp studios in berlin
herzlich willkommen zu einer besonderen
faz veranstaltung in sehr besonderen
tagen spielplanänderungen live eine live
show zur feier des im moment still
gelegten theaters ich freue mich sehr
dass sie alle dabei sind
mein name ist simon strauß ich arbeite
im filter der faz und bin dort für das
theater zuständig vor mehr als einem
jahr haben wir in der zeitung eine serie
gestartet die zu unrecht in
vergessenheit geratene theaterstücke
wiederentdeckt und präsentiert hat
daraus ist ein buch geworden und eine
veranstaltung in der berliner volksbühne
dort haben am vergangenen wochenende
über 30 künstlerinnen und künstler
theater gespielt gesungen getanzt
debattiert und ein zeichen gesetzt für
das dramatisch vergessene
beziehungsweise vergessen dramatische
theater und weil sie aus den bekannten
gründen nicht dabei sein konnten haben
uns überlegt dass wir ihn nicht einfach
einen stream ein video der veranstaltung
auf die website stellen wollen sondern
ihn in einer moderierten live schau
höhepunkte und ausschnitte dessen
präsentieren wollen
was dort an dem tag geschah das was sie
in den nächsten zwei stunden hier
zusammen mit mir in ausschnitten sehen
können können sie danach in voller länge
auf unserer website oder der website
einer unserer partner volksbühne berlin
oder auch rwe online in ganzer länge
sehen
finanziert hat dieses große abenteuer
neben der faz und dem tropen bzw
klett-cotta verlag vor allem die heinz
und heide durch stiftung in berlin die
trotz aller hindernisse verschiebungen
und hürden nie ihre unterstützung
aufgekündigt hat und dafür schon mal an
dieser stelle ein herzlicher dank
neben einer zeitung die so etwas möglich
macht und engagierte förderung die
künstlerinnen und künstler bezahlen
obwohl sich die lage deutlich verändert
hat braucht man für so ein theater tag
in corona tagen auch eine regie die
ruhig bleibt und kreativ umgeht mit den
veränderten situationen und
herausforderungen bevor er den ersten
videoausschnitt sehen freue ich mich
daher dass ich ihnen den
verantwortlichen regisseur des abends
inova vorstellen darf der uns aus der
schweiz zu gescheitert ist guten abend
ziehen hallo simon der besonderen
bedingungen in einer leeren volksbühne
inszeniert sehen die lehrer volkswagen
hier im hintergrund
wie war das für dich mit was für einem
gefühl hast du hast ihn irrt ja es ist
eine total merkwürdige zeit im moment
gehört natürlich theater zu machen weil
ist ja so ist das die theater der
betrieb läuft weiter aber es dürfen
keine zuschauerinnen und zuschauer mehr
brauchen das heißt man arbeitet weiter
hinter den bühnen wir als gäste kamen in
die volksbühne haben da dann trotzdem
arbeiten können und trotzdem diese
vergessenen stücke aufzeichnung der
moment als das unvergessene stücken
aufzeichnen können und dann ist man
wieder gegangen aber es war keiner da
der einen gesehen hat und das ist
natürlich total merkwürdiges gefühl
umgekehrt ist aber total wichtig dass
man im moment auch so etwas macht dass
man etwas tut dass man nicht gefühl hat
wir müssen jetzt nur abwarten und
beleidigte hause warten sondern dass man
versucht mit den gegebenen maßnahmen um
zu gehen und etwas zu tun und indem dass
man etwas tut auch mit kritik zu üben
also gab es mir das leben zu nehmen
und ich glaube das war irgendwie ein
sehr spezieller moment weil man so in
diesem punkt diese lehre volksbühne
reinkam und die soviel tag befüllen oder
für zwei tagen so befüllen und füllen
konnte und dann für das endlich wieder
im gang ist und es gab gar nicht diese
trainieren
die man sonst so von theater arbeiten
kennt ja du sprichst es schon an
ursprünglich ging es um die vergessenen
stücke dann bestimmten moment in diesem
ganzen projekt ging es ja darum das
theater insgesamt vor dem vergessen zu
bewahren
hast du das gefühl dass du ein
besonderes zeichen gesetzt hast mit
dieser ja nun auch schicksalhaften titel
spielplanänderungen hast du ein zeichen
gesetzt hat dass man trotzdem etwas
gemacht hat in dieser schwierigen zeit
ja absolut also ich finde sie sind die
total relevant ich gerade schon gesagt
habe dass das man versucht jetzt
irgendwie mit den sachen umzugehen und
es war ja irgendwie was man muss sich
etwas zu geben mittlerweile eine schöne
doppelung die sich ergeben hat nämlich
dass wir mit vergessenen stücken mit
vergessenen texten wirklich gegen das
vergessen des theaters was gemacht haben
dass wir versucht haben trotz aller
gegebenheiten mit diese texte auf eine
bühne zu bringen und mit diesen texten
zusammen eigentlich auch ein zeichen zu
setzen dass es in den theatern weiter
gibt und dass wir daran glauben das ist
total wichtig ist die lehre des theaters
muss ja für einen theatermacher für dich
eine besondere atmosphäre sei nichts
passiert dir denn wenn du an einem
geschlossenen theater im moment vorbei
geht das geht ja eigentlich am meisten
gerade ja ich glaube so wenn man auf
neudeutsch sagt der unique selling point
oder so dass wichtige und das
einzigartig am theater ist ja diese
unmittelbar haid dieser art den man
gemeinsam teils dieses dieses erlebnis
das man live an einem in einem moment
zusammen in einem raum hat und das finde
ich schon das ist eine total etwas total
wichtig ist was sehr fehlt das hat man
in gruppenprozesse das hat man vor allem
auf die zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
bei den vorstellungen
und das ist glaube ich etwas total werk
alles was es zu erhalten gibt weil ich
glaube das fehlt mir sehr aber es fehlt
auch sehr vielen anderen leuten
vielen dank vielen dank chile und das
fehlt vielen leuten das fehlt uns vor
allem deswegen haben wir das trotz allem
gemacht und jetzt schauen wir hinein in
die ersten 30 minuten der autos
videoausschnitt spielplanänderungen sie
hören sie eine sammlung von texten die
längst vergessen sind eine sammlung von
momenten gegen das verschwinden des
theaters 67 figuren aus verloren
gegangenen studien die dem spielplan
abhanden gekommen sind die ausgesondert
wurden für nicht systemrelevant erklärt
was ihnen geschah geschieht den theatern
selber es wird geschlossen ausgesondert
vergessen wir spielen an gegen das
verschwinden und ließen deshalb aus
vergessenen stücken mehr betten
gestalten zum leben und drehen die
regler mit fremder sprache buch gerade
jetzt wo alles schlafen soll monologe
szenen debatten miniaturen konzerte tanz
wir proben wir spielen wir denken weiter
denn das theater als ort der verwandlung
des zweifels des fremdseins das musste
überleben
daran wollen wir glauben davon wird man
ja wohl noch träumen dürfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine böse arbeiter mehr die sich liebe
geben hat aber deren wirklichkeit
fantastisch ergreift die mutter von
einzel lasker-schüler uraufgeführt 1919
deshalb weiter viertel eine fabrik statt
in wuppertal 3 nennen
langsam schweigend über die brücke der
einem unheimlich es ist der panel
frederik sein linkes ausgelaufenes auge
bedeckt eine schwarze klappe der zweite
ist lange anna der trägt deine hand
haben und gar an einen verschossenen
band um die schulter der dritter ist der
gläserne amadeus denn nimmt vorsichtig
plugs auf der stufe gefangen der brücke
durchlebt wird die beiden anderen setzte
sich auf das gelände der bürger der acht
weiter august und sein schwesterchen
löschen kommen dazu haben zusammen kommt
ja schon von earl puzzle alter häuser
matthäus du blut ist ja erstens mal
bluten auf den nasen rennen
das fängt auch angeschaut zu reden auf
ein traum dies kann erst trocknet immer
lassen sagt man still
es gibt noch was hinter der düsterkeit
weidmann wenn es erst licht wird hier
hast du nicht das gemäuer machen
versteckte visage in dein schatz ist
deckelchen schöne wetter für seinen
pinsel raushängen
ich habe angst wir wollen beim mutter
gehen
dann erhebt es ist auch zeit macht euch
nach hause kleines bald gehörte ich mir
auf der straße
ich sag euch lang mache ich so ein leben
nicht mehr mit wenn du friederich was
hast du von deinem leben
ich hab nix ums leben es wird zum
zeitvertreib oder falls zeitvertreib
nichts für seine freundin katzi gefühl
dass eine charge wir will dann holt sie
mir aus seiner kiste und von den tieren
rannten bekommt man selten der fall
fehlen ihnen den die buchsen
ich mache ich oft zum opernball ersten
dich nicht kriegen tun wenn unsere
sachen selber was hast du eigentlich von
der sauerei und guckst man immer so wird
es eine original kopf frei sich immer
lauter dem muttertier und die hatten
mittel dafür aus dem zuchthaus kirchhof
rät sie die totenköpfe und treibt sie zu
zucker mit
nein so und wartest auf mich und im
zweifel bis du wie medea dir begegnen
möchte nachdem sie deiner liebe ziel
erfahren dass tiefer dein vertrauen zu
mir nicht könnte schmerzen jedoch
verschwindend kleine sorgen vor dem
größten glück und größtes glück für mich
mein sohn ist eine heirat
zwar endet an dem tag an dem ich braut
und bräutigam zum braut begleiten ein
letztes recht an deine herrlichkeit
vergessen dass ich deine mutter war muss
ich danach geduldig üben und schatten
eines glücks nur ist es wenn freundlich
man mir sagt dass ich großmutter heiße
doch einem glückstag opfert man das
sorgen reiche leben gern
und das will ich seit dem siebenten
lebensjahr ist fern du meiner pflege
schnitzt sich doch bogen schwert und
spies und
was ein knabe lieben mag doch besser mit
der männer hände
zwar wären meine hände foul den ich
gewesen waren sie doch regen nicht den
geist des jüngeren bruders zu
befriedigen
es zog zum vater dich zu männern dich da
widerstehen ist der frauen
hoffnungsloses mühe dass ich versuchte
und so steht die früchte schmerzlicher
geburt von deiner schönheit ab zu
pflügen mißlang und zeigte wieder wellen
gegen mich in dir
du warst von meinen augen fort gerückt
nicht etwa dass sofern war es durch die
jahre ich sah den edlen gang an dir und
deiner hände mannigfache taten und eines
auges augen leuchten
da was jeden ausgestellt doch deine
ganzheit sah ich nicht doch wonach sich
mütter sehen deines leibes blühen reifen
nicht was sklaven du vergönnt ist
badelt dich zu schauen da ich nicht dein
vater erntete das glück dass ich mir
einst erhoffte und zuflucht meiner
wünsche blieb die eine nacht in der ich
dem gesetz gehorchen dir und deiner
braut die kerzenhalter dann werde ich
dich sie und was mein leib geboren
erfahren endlich warum alt und
gebrechlich schauen was mein inneres
auge bildete vergaß ich doch kein zartes
fältchen und keiner muskelspiel in
meinem herzen
das ist mit schönheit überhäufte und mit
gebärden wie bildhauer sich die götter
denken wenn sie ihnen nackt erscheinen
und siegen wirst du über mich der
übleren an allem
demütig werde ich werden und mit dem
mysterium der liebe beugen nicht länger
locken gegen meines woche storm verehren
lernen neidlos lieben werde das
männliche ich das über uns hinweg stammt
wie die stiere nicht zweifle daran dass
mein segen dich begleiten wird
nur eines zeigt mir an
dass meine augen sehn sucht die nicht
lästig sein wird
[Musik]
der neue renault sa oder geschichte des
kubanischen präsent an die von jakob
michael reinhold lenz ein text von 1774
eines kompromisslosen modernen der
schonungslos missstände benannte deren
thematisierung zeitgenossen in diese
form vermieden
[Musik]
ich reise aber nicht vorwärts zurück
ich habe genug gesehen und gehört das
wird mir zum ekel nach kuba nach kuba
einmal wieder atem zu schöpfen
ich glaube deiner welt zu sein wo ich
edlere leute antreffen als bei mir große
viel umfassende viel tätige ich entdecke
wollen sie zur ader lassen spottet ihr
nein
in der tat sich sie zu blut reich ich
glaubte im hastigen reden wäre etwas
zugestoßen den eure morast ersticke ich
tribes nicht länger meine seele nicht
dass der aufgeklärte welt teil
allenthalben wo man hinrich lässigkeit
faule ohnmächtige begleitender tod für
für feuer und leben geschwätz für
handlung dass der berühmte welt teil
obwohl doch noch erlauben sie sie sind
noch jung und dann sind sie ein fremder
und wissen sich viel in unsere sitten zu
schicken und zu rücken
das ist nun nichts gerät ohne verurteilt
mein freund ganz mit kaltem blut
ich fürchte mich weiter zu gehen wenn
mein missvergnügen immer so zunimmt wie
bisher
aber wisst ihr was die ursache ist das
eure sitten nur fremden so auffallen
ich mag nicht reden ich müsste
entsetzlich weit ausholen ich will euch
zufrieden lassen und nach hause reisen
und unschuld meine mütterlichen
besitztümer zu genießen mein land
regieren und mauren herum ziel dass
jeder der aus europa kommt erst
quarantäne hält er seine festball unter
meinem untertan war vielfältig auch das
ist erstaunen tat allerliebste prinz ich
wünschte gern dass sie eine gute meinung
von uns mit nach hause nehmen
sie haben sich noch nicht um unseren
garten und feld baugb kümmert aber was
sie sind noch jung
sie müssten sich ein 10 20 jahre
wenigstens bei uns aufhalten
bis das sie lernten wo wir ist alle
anderen nationen in der ganzen welt
zuvor getan ihn betrügen in der spitze
bereits nicht vom feld bau und sie alles
zugestanden
ich baue zuerst mein herz denn um mich
herum alles zugestanden ihr wisst
erstaunlich aber er tut nichts
ich rede nicht von ihm sie sind der
wackers der europäer den ich das bitte
ich mir aus ich habe den ganzen tag der
echten ich wollte sagen ihr wisst nichts
alles was ihr zusammengestoppelt bleibt
auf der oberfläche ihres verstandes wird
zulässt nicht zu empfinden
ihr kennt das wort nicht einmal was ihr
empfindung nennt ist schminke womit ihr
brutalität bestreicht seit wunderschöne
masken mit lastern und niederträchtig
keiten ausgestoppt wie ein fuchs bald
mit herz und eingeweide sucht man
vergeblich
die sind schon zwölf jahre zu einem
teufel in der 77
[Musik]
strahlend
ein unglück dass man nicht alleine stand
ist weniger eindeutig und weniger mit
auf den weg ihr habe ich darüber
nachgedacht
wenn ich einmal hinein gehen muss ich
gleich anfangen zu reden
noch ein paar worte wissen sie bescheid
und ich habe nichts mehr zu sagen wenn
wir zusammen eigentlich sagen
beispielsweise nachbarn umschweife man
halten sie so gefunden ihre hände
gefaltet geredet aber nicht gefallen sie
unsere könig redet man dann hören sie
uns zu untergehende stellende schlechte
nachricht ins auge zu sehen
es ist wichtig dass man ein bisschen
rechts im kreise der unglücklichen dass
man sie nicht sich selbst überlassen
doch die am wenigsten beteiligt neben
unbewusst enthält des schmerzes absicht
noch die wenigsten beteiligten nähmen
bewusst einen teil des schmerzes
nicht
[Musik]
nach einem kurzen stück zu einer von
maurice maeterlinck folgt tage linstow
eine abrechnung mit der russischen
justiz und bürokratie von alexander
zubkow gewinn ein stück welches nach
seiner erscheinung 1869 über 30 jahre
verboten wurde
bis das buch geführt werden konnte so
gut ich war schloss mir reicht selbst
meine vorgesetzten reißt mich in stücke
wenn die gläubiger nageln an meinem sagt
ich habe die misere sei also werde ich
das zeitliche segnen aber wie ein hund
kapieren will ich das hat noch lange
nicht an gar nicht in frage eines
natürlichen todes sterben immer die
natur und ihre gesetze das ist was für
idioten karekin sterbe wie es mir passt
wo es mir passt und woran es mir passt
verstanden kommt tod wo ist dein stachel
du machst einen plagen ein ende
also her mit dir und schluss mit den
schulden
schluss mit den rechnungen und schluss
mit der pumpe rey gibt wohl ihr herren
da oben oder unten
ich bitte um vergebung meine herren
vorgesetzten obwohl meine freunde meine
totengräber ihr feigen hunde karelin ist
nicht mehr friede sein gebäude oder oder
brauchen sie vielleicht auch einen
verwalter ich bin wirklich ein
glänzender geschäftsmann wenn sie sich
überzeugen wollen bitte hier sind meine
zeugnisse meiner erfahrung sind wirklich
außerordentlich vielschichtig ich bin
durch dick und dünn gegangen ganz zu
schweigen von einer unendlichen
redlichkeit meine herren das ist eine
einmalige gelegenheit
nein sie ist nicht interessiert dann
dann möchte ich sie aber bitten sich
zumindest meine adresse zu notieren für
den fall dass sie es sich noch einmal
überlegen ja bitte schreiben sie
oder wollen sie nicht vielleicht auch
gleich ganz zu greifen
ich bin auch in finanzierung äußerst
versiert dafür ein mann wie mich hat die
geschäftswelt keinerlei geheimnisse mit
einem wort ich biete ihnen produktivität
zuwachsraten gewinnchancen dass ihnen
der verstand stehenbleibt schlagen sie
diese hand nicht zurück schenken sie mir
ihr vertrauen ich sehe schon
wir sind schon sie denken sie können das
auch ohne mich da sind sie sich da
sicher von oder später wird es ihnen
leid tun
alleine können sie das doch gar nicht
hält sie brauchen einen fachmann sie
brauchen einen berater
sie brauchen einen vampir
[Musik]
iwan turgenjew ein monat auf dem lande
in diesem stück gibt es nur ein thema
die liebe
nirgendwo sonst findet man so viel
verzweiflung ihre dass jung sensors und
berechnung durch alle altersklassen
hindurch wird die möglichst unmögliche
verbindung gesucht hängt für allein
natalie betroffen sagen sie mir was mit
ihnen los ist nichts michael gar nichts
und wenn etwas war es vorbei das kann
doch jedem passieren oder auch über den
himmel ziehen wollten
wieso schauen sie mich so an
nur so ich bin glücklich öffnen sie das
fenster der garten ist so herrlich grüßt
dich mit als hätte er nur auf die
gelegenheit gewartet herein zu wählen
in windeseile hatte das ganze zimmer
erobert jetzt lässt er sich nicht
verjagen
sie sind jetzt so sanft und still wieder
abend nach einem gewitter nach einem
gewitter
gab es denn ein gewitter es hat sich nur
zusammengebraut
tatsächlich wissen sie michael ich kann
mir keinen menschen vorstellen
der gutmütige wäre als sie lassen sie
mich ausreden
sie sind tolerant liebenswürdig verlässt
sie verändern sich nicht
ich habe ihnen viel zu verdanken
nur sagen betonte wieso sagen sie dass
ausgerechnet jetzt 30 nicht ich bin
fröhlich entspannt
lassen sie mich klappe
sie sind ein engel heute morgen hätten
sie das nicht gesagt
hören sie michael sie kennen mich
sie müssen mir verzeihen unser
verhältnis ist so rein so aufrichtig und
trotzdem nicht ganz natürlich ihr zwei
können nicht nur arkadi mann mann
sondern der ganzen welt offen in die
augen sehen ja aber und genau das
belastet beschenkt und ärgert mich und
wie ein kind will ich meinen ärger nem
anderen auslassen besonders gern an ihn
hätte ihn dieses privileg nicht auf die
nerven
im gegenteil manchmal macht es spaß den
zug wählen den man liebt ja den man
liebt auch ich kann wie tatjana sagen
wozu noch heute betroffene sie ja ich
liebe sie aber wissen sie rapid hin was
mir manchmal komisch vorkommt ich liebe
sie nur ist dieses gefühl so abgeklärt
so friedlich es erregt mich nicht
es wärmt mich aber sie haben mich nie
zum weinen gebracht und es wäre zwingend
notwendig glaub ich
was bedeutet das diese frage beantwortet
sich von selbst
wir kennen uns schon so lange vier jahre
ja wir sind alte freunde freunde
nein sie sind mehr für mich als ein
freund und alle betroffenen lassen sie
dieses thema ich fürchte um mein glück
es könnte in ihren händen zerbrechen
nein nein nein
die krux ist sie sind zu gutmütig zu
tolerant mehr gegenüber
sie haben mich verwöhnt seien sie nicht
so gut
die hören sind ich höre ich weiß nicht
wie sie das sehen
ich persönlich wünsche mir kein anderes
glück viele würden mich beneiden nicht
wahr
ich bin ihnen hilflos ausgeliefert
machen sie mit mir was sie wollen ich
kann ihnen jetzt nicht sehen will später
was ist das der anfang vom ende
oder das ende schlechthin
oder hätte er anfangen
ich hab dich einmal geküsst
ich habe mich zweimal geküsst
[Musik]
beim lied habe ich gewusst wie du bist
ich hab ich einmal gewagt
ich hab dich zweimal gefragt
doch ihr betrieb hier endlich ja gesagt
[Musik]
haben sie das gesehen diesen übermut
diese spielfreude dieses unbedingte
verwandlung glück in den gesichtern
dieser fantastischen schauspielerinnen
und schauspieler
was ist das ist das der anfang vom ende
oder ein neuer anfang heißt es bei jenny
und vielleicht ist das ja jetzt gerade
wirklich einen moment in dem sich die
dinge neu ordnen
in dem man zeit hat über die welt nach
kona nachzudenken insbesondere die
theaterwelt wo eine lücke ist und immer
neue pläne schmieden neue gedanken
entwickeln kann
der ursprüngliche impuls dieser ganzen
unternehmung spielplanänderungen war wie
gesagt die dramaturgin an den vielen
fantastischen theater in dieses landes
dazu anzuregen ihre spielpläne
vielfältiger unordentlicher zu machen
denn jenseits der evergreen stil als
kanon oder klassiker landauf landab
immer wieder gespielt werden gibt es
eben eine ungeheure vielzahl von
vergessene dramatik von verloren
gegangener verloren gegangen stücken die
unbedingt wieder entdeckt gehören und
auf die bühnen der theater drängen
ein paar haben sie eben in ausschnitten
angespielt gesehen wir haben diese
vielzahl von stücken auf 30 vorschläge
in der zeitung erster sein reduziert von
ganz unterschiedlichen autorinnen und
autoren vorgeschlagen er ist in der
serie spielt keine anderen dann in dem
buch spielplan änderung dass beim tropen
verlag herausgekommen ist 30 stücke die
das theater heute braucht natürlich ist
es etwas provokant etwas übermütig etwas
angriffslustig vielleicht das wort
braucht aber vielleicht ist das jetzt
doch wirklich der moment wo das theater
etwas braucht anregungen braucht neue
kraft neuen anschub damit es nach corona
und die vorhänge wieder aufgehen mit
einem neuen ideenreichtum überzeugen
kann darum worum es in diesem buch
ergeht wie sie es glücklich erwerben
können hören wir jetzt zwei wunderbare
buchhändler aus potsdam aus dem
phänomenalen theater verrückten
literatur laden bist unser literaturland
sehr theater abwiegen und dieses buch b
planänderung mit ausrufezeichen ist eine
wahre entdeckungsreise
ja warum ist das buch jetzt gerade so
wichtig dieses buch die anthologie
herausgegeben von simon strauß
beinhaltet 30 theaterstücke die das
theater heute umso mehr braucht um die
bühne zu reformieren und gerade in
dieser zeit wo die theater nicht offen
sein dürfen ist das hoch der perfekte
begleiter und das theater nach hause zu
holen in den kopf zu holen und weiter
dabei zu sein weiter dabei zu bleiben
das theater lebt weiter auch in diesem
buch und die art und weise wie es
geschrieben wurde nimmt mit kleinen
dialogischen ausschnitten und mit sehr
individuellen beschreibung dessen was da
in diesen theaterstücken passiert die
wieder neu entdeckt wurden
das natürlich auch eine serie hält in
der unser geistvoll art und weise mit
theater weiter zu beschäftigen
wir haben aus dem literaturland zehn
bücher die wir gratis verschicken wollen
die mich an die die uns schreiben sie
uns eine mail schicken an folgende
adresse info at wisst wst - der
literatur laden klein und
zusammengeschrieben punkt de
ja meine damen und herren auf die plätze
fertig los die ersten zehn e mails die
jetzt an info at - der literatur laden
punkt de geschickt werden erhalten das
buch zur sendung gratis und alle anderen
bezahlen mit dem buch gewissermaßen
einen solidarischen eintrittspreis für
diesen theaterabend und unterstützen
nebenbei auch eine wunderbare
buchhandlung die wie so viele andere
auch gerade durch eine schwere zeit geht
also info at - der literatur laden
punkt.de ansonsten gibt es das buch
natürlich auch im buchladen ihrer wahl
ende der werbe durchsage unser nächsten
gesprächsgast kennen sie aus dem kino
etwa aus den sehr berührenden film
schwesterlein der vor kurzem angelaufen
ist und jetzt weil die kinos ja auch zu
sind hat er auch nicht zu sehen ist oder
aus dem fernsehen morgen abend etwa
können sie ihn als rechtsanwalt biegler
sehen in der ard verfilmung von
ferdinand von schirachs neuesten
theaterstück gott aber wenn sie ihn
wirklich kennen dann kennen sie den
schauspieler lars eidinger von der bühne
da wo er stanley kowalski hamlet oder
richard den dritten gespielt hat oder
zuletzt ein mit allen wassern der
flirrenden gegenwart gewaschenen peer
gynt der so lange so tief in sich selbst
sucht bisher einen zerkratzten spiegel
findet jeweils eidinger ich frage nicht
dass du heute abend hier bist ja ich
freue mich auch sehr abenteuerlich über
dieses programm
ich weiß ich hab das dann die benutzt
ehrlich gesagt ist aber sieht sich aber
wunderbar ein dritter hinter dir ja
genau ich trete in ein frankfurter
tatort und morgen früh ging hier im
frühstücksfernsehen in köln deswegen
nicht jetzt kalten teilen um aufmerksam
zu machen auf gott wirst du gerade schon
erwähnt hast was morgen abend um 20 15
im ersten läuft macht viel fernsehen
gerade du spielst viel vor der kamera
das machst du sowieso schon länger und
so aber jetzt sind die theater zu
bedeutet das für dich etwas
besonderes dass du also du spielst aber
du spielst nicht auf der bühne das
bedeutet das für dich dass du nicht auf
der bühne stehen kann es im moment ja
ich halte mich so ein bisschen an dem
fernsehen fest im moment also es war
ziemlich schnell klar dass ich während
des zweiten lok da und sie zum november
drehen kann was mir geholfen hat dann
war es kurioserweise sodass es hieß ich
sollte ihr zum ersten drehtag anreisen
es gibt einen positiv getesteten
komparsen ich soll noch mal zu hause
bleiben
drei tage später hieß es es gibt jetzt
viel positive tests und der ganze tatort
oder abgesagt und dann gab es noch mal
der nachricht alle vier tests waren
falsch und wir drehen jetzt doch und ich
hab ich hab' ich habe einfach gemerkt
wie bisher wird es geholfen hat aber es
ersetzt das theater natürlich nicht ich
habe das große glück dass ich jetzt im
oktober fast zwei wochen was ja gegen
unser prinzip ist eigentlich aus
mitspielen konnte per günther und ich
also ich sage mal so ganz blöd
pathetisch ich habe am ende jedes mal
geweint weil ich einfach so vermisst
tage und war jetzt so glücklich war mit
den leuten direkt in austausch zu kommen
und ich habe auch gespürt dass es den
leuten ähnlich gehen und ich meine du
weißt es aber der hatte die unsicherheit
ist der große trumpf des theater hat und
das habe ich mir auch schon immer auf
die fahne geschrieben ist dass das ist
aber sich ausspielen will und ich glaube
das ist auch das was dem theater das
theater allen anderen medien voraus hat
und deswegen haben wir jetzt auch ein
sehr junges publikum unser publikum ist
zwischen 20 und 40 und finden da raus
und theater das sie woanders nicht
finden und danach suchen sie und das
erleben sie und deswegen ist das theater
im grunde auch die dinosaurier man macht
sich etwas vor was denkt die die dinge
saurier haben ganz kurz gelebt und dann
kann die menschen es ist ja genau
umgekehrt schlägt die weltgeschichte
eine stunde ist dann hat der mensch
nicht eine sekunde gelebt und rest der
zeit der dinosaurier
ich glaube tatsächlich auch wenn ich mir
natürlich sorgen um das theater mache
habe ich glaube das theater
wird alles überleben also wer hätte
gedacht du bist ja mobil als sich aber
ich bin jahrgang 76 wer hätte gedacht
dass es fernsehen machen die krise kommt
also wer hätte gedacht dass meine
tochter vielleicht schon bald in ihrem
leben im fernsehen den fernseher
angemacht hat sehr schön wie du es
beschreibst ich mein dein theater für
die diese nicht wissen ist die berliner
schaubühne der intendant der berliner
schaubühne thomas ostermeier hat ja
gesagt dass aus seiner perspektive ist
das sinnvollste wäre jetzt eigentlich
bis zum sommer die theater zuzulassen
was für eine was für ein gefühl hast du
bei so einem bei so einem satz also
findest du das verständlich oder oder
schnitt sie da doch die kehle zu ich
habe mit ihm jetzt nicht darüber
gesprochen mein erster impuls war das
ist jetzt natürlich sagt weil die
schaubühne ist ein teilweise privates
theater es ist nicht 100 prozent
staatlich subventioniert das heißt in
dem moment profitiert türen öffnen aber
nur vor einem drittel leute spielen
schreiben wir rote zahlen und ich glaube
er weiß dass das theater wenn es offen
ist die schaubilder unter den
bedingungen auf kurz oder lang pleite
gehen würde und deswegen sagte er lasst
uns die theater zu machen weil mit
kurzer wir besser die mitarbeiter mit
kurzarbeit bezahlt werden und und dann
dann geht es also es gibt was nicht geht
ist die leute voll zu bezahlen so wie es
jetzt im oktober war und nur ein drittel
der plätze besetzen zu können
das rentiert sich nicht das ist bei
allen anderen bei allen staatlichen
theatern anders und das ist im grunde
egal wie viele leute da drin sitzen bei
uns war es schon immer existenziell und
ich mein die schau wieder war schon
immer im vergleich zu allen anderen
theatern in berlin unterfinanziert und
ist ja kein geheimnis dass die
gastspiele so schön sie sind nur den den
einzigen grund haben dieses theater zu
finanzieren wir haben uns in den 20
jahren die wir an
die thomas muster mal die künstlerische
leitung von der schaubühne wanderung hat
haben wir uns nur über die gastspiele
finanziert nicht über die veredelung
das ist jetzt natürlich genau auch eine
große gefahren wenn es keine gastspiel
länger gibt und für die für die
finanzielle situation habe man sie da
geht jeder der jetzt zusammenzug und
denkt kurzarbeiter da sitzen die zu
hause und der steuerzahler muss es
bezahlt ist speist sich tatsächlich aus
den rücklagen die die schauspieler
selber gemacht haben würde jahre also
dass der steuerzahler muss da nicht
herhalten wenn man noch mal kurz auf die
ich als schauspieler komme nicht meine
ich finde immer ist so eindrucksvoll
wenn man dich sieht in babylon berlin zb
im tatort aber auch jetzt in dem schon
angesprochenen gott in der verfilmung
von schirach dann hat man das gefühl das
ist sozusagen ein anderer ein anderer
schauspieler als der den man zum
beispiel bei peer gynt diesen
wahnsinnigen abend der vollständigen
endlösung sagen wenn mal seelischen
endlösung körperlichen endlösung des
wirklichen spielens um alles geht ist
das ist das so sind das zwei
verschiedene sozusagen schauspiele
identitäten die du hast wie du auf dem
theater hass und auf dem auf der
leinwand
also ich kann verstehen dass man jetzt
dass der eindruck entsteht aber es ist
glaube ich
es kommt alles aus dem gleichen ansatz
und es gibt glaube ich sehr
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen
sowohl beim filmemachen bei regisseuren
bei theater machen aber auch bei
schauspielern es gibt schauspieler die
haben eine frau die sie jedem stoff
überstunden und ist meist auch gar nicht
werden dass tatsächlich einfach
herangehensweise bei mir ist es so dass
der stoff die form bestimmt dh je
nachdem
nur nicht hatten je nach dem thema und
je nach der auseinandersetzung verändert
sich auch meine art zu spielen aber es
ist nichts was ich von außen sozusagen
dem dem überstülpen sondern es ist was
auch dass ich reagiere
und es sind auch ganz selten sachen die
ich mir vorher überlegen oder ich je
länger ich den beruf mache je mehr
möchte ich eigentlich aus dem
gestalterischen moment heraus kommen
weil ich an denen ich glaube weil er
tatsächlich etwas rückwärtsgewandtes hat
wenn ich mir vorher überlegen wie ich es
mache und setzt das dann um dann hat es
in dem moment nicht die gültigkeit dies
erfahren könnte und das ist für mich ja
auch der grund warum ist so ein theater
verteilt weil es theater im gegensatz
zum film beispielsweise wird die
vergänglichkeit und die endlichkeit
feiert und kultiviert und der film das
sagt ja schon das vokabular beim film
sagt in die szene ist gestorben und
versucht was festzuhalten und das
widerspricht eigentlich dem leben
theater heißt loslassen und daran glaube
ich und das ist auch die schönheit und
deswegen das theater auch im vergleich
oder man kann es ganz gut vergleichen
finde ich mit mit schnittblumen wenn ich
jemanden von strauß blumen überreichen
dann besteht die erotik in den morbiden
charme dass diese blumen schon vergangen
sind und eine topfpflanze hatte riesige
rot ich nicht und für mich ist der film
instant für mich ist der film was was
was eigentlich tot ist dass das theater
lebt weil es vergingen und das finde ich
über die abwesenheit von von leben über
den tod erfährt man halt mehr darüber
was es tatsächlich ist was gemeint ist
mit leben leben ist bewegung und
deswegen lautet der letzte satz bei
hamlet auch der rest ist stille stille
meint die atmosphäre die herrschten
keine anwesend ist
wir haben so lange menschen anwesend
sind bewegt sie bis ist das leben in
bewegung und und das genieße ich so dass
ich in einem raum bin und du hast es ja
auch neulich gesagt haben es gibt auch
dieses berühmte zitat von david lynch
die intelligenz in einem raum bis höher
als die summe der anwesenden und daran
glaube ich dass das was jeden verzaubert
und jeden bewegt ins theater zu gehen
wenn er das einmal erlebt hat das ist
als energetisches und das geht über das
hinaus was man allein erleben kann und
es geht über das
das ist der begriff sollten jetzt gerade
einen mattscheibe und auch getroffen und
bei unterhaltung bei entertainment geht
es um kommunikation und die findet und
theater statt in der unmittelbarkeit und
carl hegemann hat es irgendwann mal zu
mir gesagt das theater eigentlich meint
ein käfig voller tiger zu beobachten mit
dem wissen dass der käfig geöffnet ist
und das macht den stuhl aus es macht die
spannung aus und im moment wenn die rate
stationiert geschlossen um täglich und
ja im moment wie und bin ja zu ohne
unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit also
wunderbar da gehen wir es eigentlich
ganz klar wunderbare beispiele jetzt ist
der beschreibung von jugendlichen
dinosaurier überdies mit blume bis zum
tiger das sind wunderbar schreiben des
theaters sagt zum letzten zuletzt nur
die frage wir machen hier ja ein
bisschen kämpfen wir sozusagen für das
theaterstück nicht die vergessenen
theaterstücke die wir die wir
wiederentdecken wollen ist das für dich
überhaupt keine frage als schauspieler
also brauchst du für das für dein
begriff von theater theaterstücke oder
würdest du auch sagen das ist eigentlich
gar nicht so entscheidend so wichtig die
fantasie eines kollektivs arbeitet ist
gleichbedeutend mit dem theaterstück
dann gab es das absolute gegenteil ich
meine du weißt ich verehre und ich wie
sein vater verehrer und die
auseinandersetzung mit der übersetzung
von peer gynt auch nochmal mit dem autor
ibsen in meiner beschäftigung mit peer
gynt hat mir wieder mal gezeigt dass es
autoren gibt die in der lage sind etwas
zu beschreiben an dem ich mich mit
meinen horizont ein leben lang
abarbeiten kann als wenn jemand schon
mal drüber geguckt hat und über den
tellerrand und ich plötzlich mit mit
dessen augen sehen kann und plötzlich
mit tiefe oder weiter erfahren
zu der ich selber niemals in der lage
gewesen sein und ich glaube das ist auch
das was man im zuschauer
geben kann diesen blick der sich dann
vermittelt in der beschäftigung damit
und ich glaube absolut an autoren ich
bin ein großer verfechter des wortes und
ich halte immer an den worten fest ich
lege großen wert darauf und ich auf der
bühne stehe
absätze von ex temporis oder
improvisation wirklich von text zu
bleiben und ich bin sehr text genau ich
liebe shakespeare ich liebe ibsen ich
liebe übersetzung die die von botho
strauß von thomas brasch
das sind leute die welt verstanden haben
und dass das habe das tragen wir in uns
das kann uns keiner mehr nehmen sind ja
das sind ja werte die die geschaffen
wurden und die die es gilt zu bewahren
und und ich sehe meine aufgabe darin
diese autoren immer wieder sprechen zu
lassen und immer wieder zum leben zu
erwecken durch meine interpretation und
bei peer gynt ist mir das wieder mal
bewusst geworden dass ich letztendlich
so wichtig und ich mich natürlich auch
nehmer als künstlerpersönlichkeit um
einen ausdruck sehe ich mich sozusagen
stelle ich mich in dem moment in den
dienst eines autors um den bestmöglich
hörbar zu machen und und und und
sichtbar zu machen was was was weiß ich
was der in die welt getragen hat und ja
und das ist genau wie gesagt das ist ein
schatz oder dort erstens genannten
herzens über den haushalt genau es geht
um den herzens haushalt und und das ist
was ich weiß wir nicht unterschätzen
dürfen und sehr treffend und das mitten
im fitnessstudio zu vergleichen
ja das ist was die menschen bewegt und
das ist dass ich meine
jetzt kam war vom fitnessstudio die rede
schon wurde uns die leitung gekappt lars
vielen dank aber erstmal für deine
wunderbaren setzte
danke dir lass deine wunderbaren sätze
für ihn zeigen die werbung in eigener
sache dass wir das für sprechen für das
theater mit unglaublich schönen
beschreibung und ich glaube dass das
eben eine ganz besondere ausdruckskraft
hat wenn man einen schauspieler reden
hört über das was wir hier am ende ja
dann doch theoretisch verhandeln vielen
dank die wichtigkeit des theaters hat
lars eidinger gerade beschworen aber
sind die theater wirklich in unserer
gesellschaft wichtig über den betrieb
hinaus was bedeutet wichtig ist ihre
schließung ein richtiges
verantwortungsvolles zeichen in zeiten
der krise oder ein unverhältnismäßiger
eingriff in die kunstfreiheit
verfassungsfeindlich sagt etwa der
berliner kunst anwalt peter raue dazu
dass die theater am besten bis zum
sommer offen es kann schon zitiert ruft
der intendant der berliner schaubühne
thomas ostermeier zurück was muss wie
verteidigt bzw
ausgehalten werden geht es nach kona
weiter ist die zukunft des theaters
digital oder lebt es weiter von der
unmittelbarkeit des verwandlung spiels
was kann eine kulturpolitik machen damit
die verteilungskämpfe die drohen nicht
die kostbare einzigartige
subventionierte theaterlandschaft in
deutschland antastet oder sollte man sie
gerade antasten das sind alles
umstrittene fragen die letztes
wochenende im roten salon der volksbühne
im rahmen einer prominent besetzten
podiumsdiskussion diskutiert und
debattiert wurden moderiert hat sich
jürgen kaube der herausgeber des fällt
aus der faz und gehören jetzt in die
ersten zehn minuten hinein
guten abend oder guten tag meine damen
und herren
spielplanänderungen heißt der titel der
diskussion die wir jetzt gleich führen
werden damit war ursprünglich verbunden
eigentlich die idee stücke die selten
oder gar nie gespielt werden vorschlagen
und darüber zu sprechen warum sie nicht
gespielt werden
ob sie gespielt werden sollten was in
ihnen drin steckt zweimal haben wir
versucht die pandemie hat uns einen
strich durch die rechnung gemacht aber
jetzt findet trotzdem eine diskussion
statt oder demselben titel aber zu einem
anderen thema nämlich die große spiel
planänderung liebe augenblick
stattfindet nämlich das gar nicht
gespielt wird wir sind jetzt in dem
zweiten lok da und er den light genannt
wird müssen nicht wenn das endet aber
wir wissen dass im augenblick eben die
theater die oper die bühnen insgesamt
genauso zusieht wie die museen und
andere veranstaltungen aus dem bereich
der kunst und darüber wollen wir jetzt
ein bisschen diskutieren was das heißt
ob das richtig so ist welche
einschätzung von kultur damit einher
geht
und ich stelle ihnen die gäste vor die
hier mit mir diskutieren werden mein
name ist glaube ich kümmere mich in der
faz um das viertel selbst schauspielerin
aus wien angereist
klaus lederer kultursenator berlins und
auch für europa zuständig thomas
oberender der intendant der berliner
festspiele und ein autor
ich fange mal an einfach fröhlich selbst
kiwi was machen sie zur zeit
ich durfte an den geänderten programm
gerade teilnehmen hier in der
wunderbaren volksbühne
ansonsten denke ich darüber nach wie es
weitergeht weil ich habe derzeit keine
proben ich glaube das ist jetzt mit der
jetzigen stunde auch geändert ich habe
gerade gehört dass es einen harten
lockdown jetzt gibt in österreich pro
stunde oder so das heißt bis jetzt
durften wir proben spielen nicht das
wird jetzt glaube ich auch hinfällig
sein das heißt jetzt muss man da die
zeit nutzen darüber nachzudenken wie man
mit dieser neuen situation die sich noch
lange hinziehen wird umgeht denn
nichtstun und abwarten kann es meines
erachtens nach nicht sein
ist es eigentlich so als schauspielerin
dass man das gefühl hat man verliert
wenn man nicht grob bei musikern liegt
das immer nahe zu sagen wenn die nicht
proben können dann dann dann kostet es
irgendwie ein die fähigkeit wie ist das
im schauspiel das ist vielleicht nicht
zu erwarten aber das ist exakt das selbe
dh die das training die elastizität die
beweglichkeit von gedanken von gefühlen
vom körper der rhein sportive effekt des
ganzen also im weitesten sinne sportiv
das spürt man wenn man das nicht tut
zumal das einem beruf ist oder eine
tätigkeit ist die sich immer im
austausch mit anderen befindet in
energien mit anderen und wenn diese
energie fehlt das spürt man sofort weil
ein ein vakuum greift und eine art von
inklusion die ist sehr unangenehm denn
ein schauspieler der spielt und tut ist
ein schauspieler der spielt und ein
schauspiel davon so versetzt ist kein
schauspieler herr lederer sie wie soll
ich sagen
verantworten doch dauernd nicht aber sie
sind an seiner umsetzung beteiligt wie
sehen sie das
wie wie sehen sie insbesondere auch die
wie soll ich sagen die die begründung
die seitens der bühnen gekommen sind
dass man sich doch so sehr um den
hygiene hygiene konzepte gekümmert hat
um den abstand dass man alles doch sehr
viel wert darauf gelegt hat der der
gesundheitspolitischen situation
rechnung zu tragen und und gleichwohl
jetzt die bühnen geschlossen sind und
die käufer sehr offen also erstmal
verantwortlich die locker und natürlich
in der weise schon mit als die
landesregierung das ganze am ende in
rechtsverordnungen gießen oder in enorm
gießen und ich habe dem zugestimmt im
senat ich habe nicht gesagt nein ich
mache das nicht mit weil die steigenden
ansteckungszahlen sind ja erst mein fakt
so und das argument nur haben wir uns
sieben monate vorbereitet ist einerseits
richtig relativiert sich andererseits
wenn wir wissen dass die kontakt
beschränkungen ja nicht nur die
situation in den einrichtungen selbst
betreffen sondern offensichtlich das
ziel ja auch darin besteht das
gesellschaftliche leben zu verlangsamen
insgesamt weniger verkehr zu erzeugen
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf also das
ist zumindest der hintergrund des ganzen
angesichts der belastungssituation im
gesundheitswesen und trotzdem bleibt
natürlich bei mir auch einen
nachgeschmack und der hat verschiedene
verschiedene richtungen ich will jetzt
mal nur eine raus greifen als jurist
kann man das gut und ist dann auf der
sicheren seite
die begründung die nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz kam war die
das versammlungsfreiheit gottesdienste
religionsausübung grundgesetzlich
geschützt sind das ist ja eine
verfassungs wertung und dass deswegen
bei grund bei diesen grundrechts
geneigten bereichen einschränkungen
jetzt nicht tun sich waren so da ist
ganz nebenbei natürlich die kunst
vergessen worden
denn auch die kunstfreiheit das 1
eine verfassungsrechtlich geschützte
betätigung und das hat gute gründe weil
man in einer offenen in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft der kunst
offenbar eine rolle zu spricht die jetzt
über das reine freizeitvergnügen
hinausgeht von dem ja in dieser
pressekonferenz die rede war also man
geht davon aus es gibt eine
gesellschaftliche funktion von kunst und
wenn man das sozusagen mit einer mit
einer seiten bemerkung abtut das hier
freizeit jetzt ist nicht die zeit für
freizeit und geselligkeit dann verkennt
dass ganz offensichtlich diese
gesellschaftliche funktion von kunst und
da muss man gar keinen großen partners
an den tag legen
ich finde das problematisch dass das so
diskussionslos so 163 gemacht worden ist
mit allen konsequenzen da spielt für
mich jetzt noch mal die frage wie viel
mühe sich in den letzten sieben monaten
gegeben wurde oder die soziale situation
der kunstschaffenden spielt auch eine
rolle aber es spielt gar nicht die
vordergründige rolle weil das problem
haben andere gesellschaftliche bereiche
natürlich auch also auch gastronomen und
gastronomen in den letzten sieben
monaten waren nicht untätig sein haben
versucht ihre ihre ihre ihre läden
kohler fest zu machen wenn man das so
sagen
also was man was was bei mir unbehagen
auslöst ist die tatsache dass im diskurs
die kunst so relativ umstandslos dem in
einer solchen krisensituation
überflüssigen oder jetzt mal für eine
weile außer kraft zu setzen
freizeitvergnügen subsumiert wird und da
sage ich mal wenn man sagt der
gottesdienst ist ein ort oder die
religionsausübung ist ein ort der
sinnsuche der der individuellen
bearbeitung auch von krisensituationen
da trifft das zumindest für die kunst
auch zu denn auch sie hilft der
erkenntnis suche auch sie ist hat ein
momentum von sinnsuche und gerade in
krisensituationen würde ich behaupten
hat es eine besondere relevanz ja und
das ist mein unbehagen würden sie denken
dass vielleicht der grund dafür ist also
die für die unterschiedliche bearbeitung
des themas religion im verhältnis zur
kunst
das ist ein gottesdienst sicht besser
abgrenzen lässt als alle möglichen arten
der kunst ausübung weil es weil es ja
man könnte ja sagen es gibt ein
kontinuum von einem ja von einem
popkonzert zu einem zu einer aufführung
der braut von messina und und das ist
beim gottesdienst doch wirklich wie soll
man sagen eingrenzbar ist das der grund
gewesen dass man das gemacht
also wenn wir davon ausgeht dass dieser
all diese maßnahmen mit einer pandemie
situation gegründet werden
dann ist so eine undifferenzierte
teilung das eine vom anderen einfach
nicht haltbar weil man könnte natürlich
auch in der kunst sagen es gibt
bestimmte betätigungen bei denen ist
alles was wir über die pandemie wissen
in besonderer weise gefährden also
geschlossene räume oder
belüftungsanlagen die klubs sind seit
märz zu vergegenwärtigen uns das mal so
da gab es nie zwischendurch eine phase
der öffnung so also man könnte schon
auch sagen es gibt bestimmte
epidemiologisch besondere
gefahrensituationen das lassen wir jetzt
mal weg haben wir in der vergangenheit
weggelassen und es gibt andere dinge die
sind relativ unbedenklich also der
wertungswiderspruch tut sich sofort auf
wenn ich eben sage ich kann in eine
galerie gehen um ein bild zu kaufen
ja wenn ich über das nötige geld
verfügen weil die kommerziellen galerien
im einzelhandel zu gerechnet sind und
folglich offen sind
ich kann aber zur gleichen zeit nicht in
eine galerie gehen um die bilder
anzuschauen weil die nicht kommerziellen
galerien gehören eben zur kultur die
kultur ist nun mal gerade also da sieht
man sozusagen dass es zumindest in der
im erklären dessen was wir da tun und
politik ist ja veranlasst die maßstäbe
warum sie dinge tut offen zu legen wo
doch zur diskussion zu stellen
zumindest einer demokratischen
gesellschaft dann zeigt sich ganz
deutlich dass die und differenziertheit
der maßnahmen da nicht bis ins letzte
epidemiologisch begründbar ist
händler wie sie das bevor wir vielleicht
auf andere aspekte von corona kommen die
das theater betreffen wie sehen sie das
als jemand der ja auch letztlich davon
betroffen ist
ja ich finde natürlich auch viel besser
in museen und theater offen sind und es
trifft uns hart dass wir den gruppen
schließen müssen es trifft uns hart dass
wir festivals an denen wir ein jahr lang
gearbeitet haben als reine online
veranstaltungen durchführen müssen
aber ich will mal sozusagen eine andere
perspektive einnehmen und sagen dass die
politische entscheidung für mich absolut
klar und verantwortungsvoll getroffen
wurde und die entscheidung ist eine der
kontakt reduzierung es geht nicht um
konzepte und wie sicher sozusagen orte
und einrichtungen sind sondern es geht
darum in bestimmten gesellschaftlichen
verkehr zu minimieren
und dann muss man sich überlegen welche
bereiche in der gesellschaft dafür das
opfer bringen und man hat sich
entschieden zu sagen die wirtschaft und
die bildung nicht und der
freizeitbereich und das ist nicht
wertend gemeint weniger und da ist es so
dass ich auch das gefühl habe das
natürlich das unendlich abgestuft in der
schicksals härte ist also wir haben wir
haben glaube ich einen großen
institution eine situation wo wir alle
sichere gehaltsempfänger bleiben
es gibt wirklich große initiativen des
staates sowohl im bereich der
gastronomie wie auch der kultur zu
helfen und zwar abgestuft und schnell
und eigentlich relativ unkompliziert
also was man jetzt bis hin zu den hilfen
für solo selbstständige die nicht mehr
nur betriebskosten sondern auch
lebensunterhalt geltend machen können
also ich finde wir leben in einem land
was relativ rücksichtsvoll und und
elastisch reagiert und mir ist diese
reaktion im grunde lieber als ein
totaler lockdown und ich freue mich im
moment in deutschland zu leben und nicht
in frankreich oder in anderen ländern
also dass ich finde eigentlich muss die
politik loben
die politik hat alles richtig gemacht
sagt thomas oberender der leiter der
berliner festspiele
dass sie die schauspielerin dörte
lyssewski naturgemäß anders und auch bei
den zukunfts entwürfen für das theater
weil man sich nicht einig ob das was für
die berliner theaterlandschaft
wünschenswert ist auch für bühnen etwa
in schwerin oder lübeck gilt darüber
streit
einig war man sich am ende der
diskussion allerdings darüber dass der
blick in den vergessenen kanon die auf
sprengung des klassiker begriffs und die
neuentdeckung von anziehenden in
vergessenheit geraten den stücken
durchaus inspirierend sein könnte gerade
in dieser zeit klaus lederer der
kultursenator berlins zeigte sich
überzeugt davon dass grundsätzlich jeder
mensch durch ästhetisch künstlerische
aufführung berührbar sei und plädierte
dafür mit alten stoffen tolle neue
sachen zu machen und ein beispiel dafür
wie man aus einem alten stoff etwas ganz
tolles neues machen kann das
präsentieren wir ihm jetzt die junge
regisseurin laura lars hat sich im
rahmen von spielplan änderung in der
stück gabriel von der französischen
schriftstellerin george sand vergibt
erstmals nur 1839 veröffentlicht handelt
dieser stoff vom jungen gabriel die an
eine adlige familie geboren und als
thronfolger aufgezogen wird bisher als
teenager erfährt dass er eigentlich eine
frau ist ein travestie spiel beginnt das
konventionelle geschlechterrollen auf
den kopf stellt und mitreißend vom
freiheitskampf einer jungen adligen
erzählt die journalistin annabelle
hirsch hat das stück letztes jahr in
einem pariser antiquariat entdeckt und
einen enthusiastisch werbenden text für
die faz darüber geschrieben
wir haben das stück dann erstmals ins
deutsche übersetzen lassen damit laura
ab sich den stoff annehmen ihn sich an
verwandeln und aufpoppen kann
sie hat also genau das gemacht was klaus
lederer sich wünscht aus einem alten
stoff etwas ganz tolles neues gemacht
in der hauptrolle als gabriel sehen sie
die schauspielerin jella haase
bekannt aus etwa aus dem erfolgs jugend
für de facto goethe oder als das
verlorene mieze in der aktuellen
neuverfilmung von berlin alexanderplatz
film ab für gabriel
woher kommen die träume
träumte ich sei eine frau
ich hatte flügel
und schwangen mich über die verwaltung
ich weiß nicht welcher idealen welt
empor
kommen das schöne gesänge ertönten
verleihen
nichts als strahlend weißen wollten
nicht
den eltern
[Musik]
in meinem schaffen
ich muss mich um
mit einem weinen
ein gefangener angetan
plötzlicher staaten am flügel
das schloss sich über mir wie eine
kristallkugel und ich schnell
an eine schwere kette legt dass ich mir
um den hals
deren gewicht nicht mehr ab und zu
seit der kindheit sollte ich von der
größe der männlichen und den
naturgegebenen und gesellschaftlich
akzeptierten schädlichkeit der
weiblichen rolle überzeugt werden ihr
könnt auf diesen tafeln befristen sehen
und man für uns anfertigen ließ hier der
raub der sabinerinnen auf dem hier
tampere von hat hier strafe der danae
und jetzt kommt mein liebstes der
verkauf von sklaven im orient auf
weiteren sind verstoßene königinnen
verraten und für echte geliebte und
hinduistische witten zu sehen die auf
den scheiterhaufen ihrer männer geopfert
werden auf allen ist die frau sklaven
eroberung eigentum die versucht sich
durch lug und trug fahrrad zeit und
unnötige verbrechen ihrer fesseln zu
entledigen um sich einer noch
erbarmungslosen vereinigung auszusetzen
in diesem prozess
und leuten die strukturen aufgezwungen
werden die das internationale kapital
für seine herrschaft braucht es geht um
die ausrichtung aller werte auf seine
prinzipien die neben den materiellen
elend von millionen
auch die armut in den köpfen und herzen
der menschen bedeutet
[Applaus]
nur zu oft wurde mir erklärt was ein
malheur ist
und wie die erbfolge eines fürstentums
mit einer dazugehörigen titel
privilegien und reichtümern auf dem
jeweils ältesten männlichen sprösslingen
übergeht wenn die eigentlich berechtigte
linie nur noch aus töchtern besteht
freilich
wenn sie nicht bescheid zu wissen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn man sich den kapitalistischen
werten unterordnet muss man ein leben in
vereinzelung akzeptieren
menschen die isoliert und ohne wirkliche
kommunikation sind sind weit davon
entfernt sich eine andere wirklichkeit
gemeinsam mit anderen auch nur
vorstellen zu können geschweige denn das
system in frage zu stellen
ich bin in einsamkeit aufgewachsen so
lange ich denken kann
aber jetzt bin ich dessen überdrüssig
ich will die welt kennenlernen von der
man mir so viel erzählt hat die männer
die man mir anpreist
gut ich bin anders kennenlernen
alles fing eines besitzen ein trotzen
gewiss überrascht euch das aber hört
mich an
man kann ein falken in einen käfig
sperren und ihnen die erinnerung und dem
instinkt freiheit vergessen lassen
ein junger mensch aber ist ein vogel der
mit einem besseren gedächtnis begabteste
wenn ich kämpfe statt auf raten
[Musik]
lieber gott
danke dass ich als frau geboren wurde
danke dass ich mir die nägel lackieren
die haare frisieren rotkäppchen film
wall entlang arielle die meerjungfrau
mensing und gleichzeitig studieren
karriere machen
vorstände leiten und kriege führen darf
danke dass dürfen noch nicht einmal ich
die da aus und dafür ist sondern dass
diese dinge von mir erwartet werden und
die welt für alle in ordnung ist wenn
ich vor stellen oder kriege führen
solange die nägel gelangt sind
[Musik]
ich soll körper sein also stelle hier
aus danke dass ich kinder kriegen kann
und danke dass ich mich genauso gut
dagegen entscheiden und sie den rest
meiner tage wort gemeinsamen
bushaltestellen trinken kann bis keiner
mehr und nicht weit
danke dass in ein anderes geschlecht an
die seite gestellt hast von dem ich mit
einem lächeln oder meinetwegen
geschlechtsverkehr bekommen kann was ich
will
danke für das schlechte gewissen der
anderen zu die letzten 10.000 jahre
unterdrückung und danke für die mit der
geste der entschuldigung demütig auf
mein konto überwiesen dann fördermittel
unter der kampagne der weiblichen blick
die gott danke dass ich eine [ __ ] sein
kann
zu dieser zeit an diesem ort als frau
geboren zu sein ist das beste
was eine kreatur und einer sonne
passieren kann
es ist also gelüftet dieses grausame
geheimnis von dem ich längst musste
er hat endlich gewagt ist mit zu
offenbaren
nach ansage
hat ihnen glauben dass ich lasse diese
unfair und ungerecht
eine komplette letzte abstatten
nun ich darauf den füßen getreten und zu
sagen
sechs dieser klasse an torten verweisen
wir dich
franziskus und frau unterdrücken für den
großteil zum start notwendig dass ich
dafür nach hause kam dass sich die
enttäuschung und unzufriedenheit der
menschen nicht in das team endlich
sondern das klassische gegen jeweils die
in der gesellschaftlichen hierarchie
weiter unten stehen
[Musik]
er wollte mich vor ein tribunal stellen
vor einer ansammlung von männern auf
mein hamster schergen zerrissen und
einblicken diesen weiblichen boosten
tönen und wozu das aber es um euer recht
auf macht und reichtum zu demonstrieren
aber diese letzte demütigung werde ich
nicht zulassen lieber will ich diese
brust zerfleischen und diesen busen
verstümmeln so dass er für die die ihn
sehen sollen ein anblick das abspielen
und niemand beim anblick meiner
loslassen kann aber freiheiten seele
nur einer kann glauben durch in bern zu
können
die verantwortung
wie der umsetzungsprozess
weiterentwickelt werden muss liegt bei
jeder und jedem einzelnen
und jeder und jede was diese
verantwortung ab
[Musik]
ihr seid in eure eigene falle getappt
ich kenne jetzt den wunden punkt ihres
hasses
es gibt
ich will euch straßen hier betrieben
[Musik]
er sagt meine leiden teilen
es hat
straflosigkeit
und die furcht vor schalke
die strafe und einen dünnen haare
ausgehen
kann
[Applaus]
von dem was sie gerade gesehen haben ist
der weg nicht weit zu dem was sie jetzt
sehen
mein kollege dietmar dath ausgewiesene
für fertige abenteuerlicher gedanken und
verfechter sphärischer welten ist ein
verehrer von peter hacks dem
wahrscheinlich edelsten geist der ddr-
dramatik eines seiner lieblings
anekdoten die ich mir gemerkt habe
schwebt gewissermaßen heimlich als
überschrift über der ganzen spiel
planänderung eine diskussion über die
hegelstraße theorie an der berliner
akademie der künste ruft heiner müller
dazwischen es gibt keine gattung ohne
schänder worauf hacks kühl paris und
zurück und nein heiner es gibt keinen
sender ohne gattung denn wo willst du
denn sonst hin schenken die gattungen
abschafft er nicht zwischen einem
theaterstück einem lyrik nach einem
roman unterscheiden will sondern nur
noch texte und abstrakte autorenschaft
kennt der welt ins leere so hackbarth
hacks stück seine kassen wieder auf der
bühne sehen aber er will noch viel mehr
vorhang auf für fünf exklusive minuten
da ist muss
je mehr darüber geredet wird auch die
theater auf sind oder geschlossen desto
weniger kann darüber geredet werden was
sie zeigen sollen das ist immer so der
inhalt geht kaputt wenn die formen sich
wichtig machen und umgekehrt in der
inhalte staat muss schrecken dann
zerfällt die form auch deswegen man
könnte sagen wenn leute angst haben zu
sterben oder wenn leute angst haben
zwangs geimpft zu werden dann hören sie
ganz auf zu denken dann sind sie auch
ganz auf zu sprechen dann stotterer
stammen sie nur noch hätte man dagegen
gehalten hätte man eine analyse der
situation hätte meine einstellung dann
könnte man reden wie der philosoph
seneca redet in dem stück seine kaz tod
von peter hacks dass ich gerne am
theater sehen würde
er sagt nämlich und geben was zu ahnen
uns verboten ist wird dulden helfen
folgen kann jemand der rückgrat hat
dulden kann ich jemand der eine form hat
die auf eine mehrheit kommt die meisten
können nicht dulden sie können auch
nicht haltung bewahren
das ist das ergebnis denn die offizielle
und geduldig und bezahlte kultur in
einem land aus bild zeitung und der
wendler und rtl2 und solchen sachen
besteht und wenn die regierung dann ihre
maßnahmen nicht mehr so begründen kann
dass die leute die erzogen sind mit
ränder und bild zeitung hat er zwei das
verstehen
dann kann sich das mitleid mit dieser
regierung im grunde in grenzen halten
der philosoph seneca in dem stück sind
im kasten von peter hacks dass ich gerne
theater sehen würde
hat diese probleme alle nicht es vom
kaiser befohlen zu sterben dann stirbt
erhalten da stellt sich dabei auch nicht
groß an
denn er weiß es kommt nicht darauf an ob
man stirbt das sterben so wie es kommt
darauf an wie man stirbt und er sagt
deshalb unter anderem auch glücklich ist
wer nicht sein denken ändern muss vor
seinem tod oder nicht erheblich
mit deutschland sind inhaltlich
auseinandersetzung und eben deshalb auch
form gar nicht so beliebt der spiegel
zum beispiel muss sich jetzt gerade
wieder dass sich die demokraten in
amerika selbst zerlegen nach beiden
gewinnen damit das gemeint dass die
inhaltliche diskussion stattfindet und
was vielleicht auch zum teil auf der
linken in der demokratischen parteien
nicht so gut findet dass da jetzt leute
von jp morgan und diese ganze bande da
wieder im übergangsteam sitzt bei ein
anderer inhalt als der der verein war
wäre schon schön gewesen auch wenn es
natürlich ein gewinn ist wenn kein
schreibender dabei setzt der keinen
geraden satz sagen kann im theater wird
anders als in der politischen arena
geschriebener text gesprochen
das heißt dann wenn sie stück aufführen
sie fühlen ja nicht immer stücke auf
sondern irgendwas anderes das ist dann
aus dem westen meistens geschriebenen
text auch zu führen kann in einer zeit
wo die leute so festhalte termine sich
suchen und über offen oder nicht offen
diskutieren kann es ganz wichtig sein
weil das eben keine bürokratischen form
sind wie die form von erlaubt verboten
und wirklichen und ausgedacht und
bürgerrechten sondern das in form der
sprache und wird schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler zumindest so tun als
könnten sie formvollendet sprechen als
könnten sie klartext oft sagen und den
mit leben füllen und mit handlungen
füllen und die gat beglaubigen
dann hat es ein motorisches moment weil
es nämlich eine gesellschaft darstellt
in der die leute nicht nur um stadt in
der die leute was zu sagen haben und es
dann auch tun
in der wirklichkeit ist ja leider so
dass immer mehr leute weil lektorate und
dramaturgie die sprache gerne
wegstreichen bevor sie sie drücken oder
aufhören können wir leute also zum
beispiel nicht mehr wissen dass hingegen
bedeutet oder indes oder obzwar und die
zeit ist deswegen wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr fern wird die leute auch nicht mehr
wissen was zwar aber bedeutet oder oder
oder
und dann haben wir die scheiße
vollständig solange es darum geht das
ist irgendwie schön aussieht
zum beispiel noch nach demokratie
aussieht nämlich nach deren formen tritt
natürlich schnell der zustand einem dass
schönheit also form also verlotterte
also zerfallene form also schön hat die
keine schönheit ist sondern einfach nur
zucker schienen den inhalt verdrängt und
deswegen findet sehr neckar in dem stück
geist soll der schönheit vorgezogen sein
und dann fragt die berliner
warum soll geist der schönheit
vorgezogen sein und dann gibt es wieder
eine antwort die mit dem titel des
stücks zu tun hat sie eine kaste nämlich
der geist im gegensatz zu schönheit
wächst ja bis zum tod
wenn das theater sich aber weigert
dieses wachsen des geistes bis zum tod
und über den tod hinaus zu spielen
sprache zu spielen wenn das
weggestrichen wird weil es alt versteht
keiner mehr lasst uns jemand video
machen wenn das theater stattdessen
sagen wir palim palim und tutti frutti
und gute zeiten schlechte zeiten aufhört
aber natürlich nackt oder in nazi
uniform weil das ist ein
gesellschaftskritik dann soll es bitte
zu bleiben
ein etwas anderer blick passt das
theater jetzt wissen sie warum die
ausführung von stücken auch richtig ist
unser abend neigt sich bereits dem ende
zu ich hoffe sie haben sich bisher gut
unterhalten gefühlt und vielleicht nicht
nur unterhalten sondern auch berührt
erstaunt haben sich gewundert und
vielleicht an der einen oder anderen
stelle sogar geärgert denn darum geht es
ja beim theater beim schauspiel das wir
uns neu ordnen und durcheinanderbringen
lassen weniger moral und erschütterung
als das unmittelbare erleben unsere
gefühlswelten und das was wir haben ohne
es zu wissen
ein strahlen strahlenden beweis für die
kraft des unmittelbaren hat am
vergangenen wochenende der schauspieler
und musiker christian spiegel mit seiner
phänomenalen bands auch von birnen aus
dresden abgeliefert ihn haben sie
vielleicht gerade als sensiblen
fotografen in babylon berlin wissen in
der leeren volksbühne spät am abend
hatte ein spektakuläres theater konzert
gegeben in dem die grenzen zwischen
gesang musik und text auf geheimnisvoll
anziehende weise miteinander
verschwanden william shakespeare ist
spätestens seit seinem legendären
dresdner hamlet in der inszenierung von
jossi vontobel ein ständiger begleiter
von christian schrieben aber exklusiv
für spielplanänderungen hat er sich auch
mit einer vergessenen dramatikerin
nämlich mit arshavin beschäftigt und
zwei jahrzehnte nach shakespeares tod
geboren war sie zu lebzeiten die erste
öffentlich auftretende schriftstellerin
englands und als dramatikerin umjubelt
später dann erinnerte man sich nur noch
an shakespeare und bin wurde vergessen
wo wir ihn nun zum abschluss ein
ausschnitt aus diesem einzigartigen
konzert vorführen freue ich mich sehr
dass uns christian friedel aus dresden
zugeschaltet ist hallo christian
hallo sie mich sehr dass du da bist
erzähl doch mal ganz am anfang wie war
das für dich die begegnung mit dieser
völlig vergessene autoren erfragen
also das war für mich sehr spannend weil
ich wusste gar nicht dass es schon eine
solch erfolgreiche schriftstellerin
autorin
sie war wohl auch spionen habe ich dann
mal nachgelesen zu shakespeares zeiten
bzw
nach sechs bis tod ein wenig sehr
erfolgreich war und dann in
vergessenheit geraten ist und als ich
diese texte bekommen habe von euch fand
ich sehr spannend
darin zu lesen und fand es auch sehr
klug geschrieben was sie dort beschreibt
sozusagen auch über ein theater publikum
von damals was dem heutigen gar nicht
mal so unähnlich ist
und was natürlich schade ist dass diese
autoren natürlich jetzt nicht die textil
über die jahrzehnte über die 100 neue
ersetzt wurde
da liegt glaube ich noch eine große
entdeckung kinder uns oder vor uns
sozusagen und vielleicht auch für
übersetzer eine spannende aufgabe weil
sich ihre stücke anzunehmen
dank dir christian dafür und wir haben
ja schon gehört ich habe gesagt dass du
nicht nur schauspieler bist ein
wunderbarer schauspieler sondern eben
auch die musik für dich eine
unglaubliche rolle spielt und dann wir
werden das gleich in dem ausschnitt auch
sehen diese sehr besonderen mischung
nicht form eigentlich die duh oder ihr
da erfunden habe wie kam es eigentlich
dazu dass du von der bühne her sich nach
einem mikrofon gesehen hast denn das zu
singen kannst ist da etwas gewesen dass
du nicht ausdrücken konnte es als
schauspieler was du dann als sänger
ausdrücken konntest
also ich glaube es ist wahrscheinlich
dem publikum gar nicht so fern das ist
schauspieler gibt die gerne singen und
auch gerne kopf deshalb möchte ich habe
schon immer gerne gesungen und habe also
eigentlich ich sage meistens kommt es
immer zusammenzufassen und kurz zu
fassen dass ich gerne die leute
unterhalten habe ob ich das nun sehen
handtuch oder schauspiel das war mir
eigentlich immer da wollte ich gar keine
prioritäten setzen und als ich dann an
die schauspielschule kam habe ich
natürlich mein hauptaugenmerk erstmal
auf das schauspiel gelegt und wir hatten
dann aber auch einen musikalischen abend
habe ich gemerkt wenn man die stimme an
setzt die stimme anhebt und dann etwas
sinkt nicht nur dass das beim publikum
andere türen öffnet es öffnet auch bei
einem selbst andere türen und ich habe
dann auch gemerkt dass das keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist dass
schauspieler nicht nur gerne singen
sondern auch singen können
viele meiner kolleginnen kolleginnen an
der schauspielschule hatten da ihre ganz
eigenen erfahrungen gemacht und manche
haben sogar angst davor
sie haben sich das herz herausgerissen
beim schauspiel aber sie hatten angst
davor ihre seele zu zeigen wenn sie
singen und das fand ich ganz ganz
spannend und da habe ich gemerkt dass
das nicht interessante mischform sein
kann dass es momente gibt die vielleicht
auch dann mehr zu herzen gehen oder
vielleicht inhalte anders öffnen können
wenn man sie musikalisch betrachtet und
es ist immer interessant eine brücke zu
finden von spiel in den gesang und
wieder zurück das muss irgendwie stimmen
und damit es nicht ganz zu musical haft
ist um ohne dass jetzt abzuwerten weil
beim musical ist ja genau das was man
mit der sprache nicht mehr ausdrücken
kann wird dann eben eine nummer oder in
ein gesang gepackt und wenn man sich
aber bei shakespeare zb gesanglich dort
hinein begibt dann ist es meistens ein
auch eine atmosphärische kick die man
darauf vertiefen kann sozusagen mit der
mit ihm gesagt dass du dich so viel mit
shakespeare beschäftigt erübrigt
eigentlich die frage ob tier
theaterstücke wichtig sind aber ich will
trotzdem noch mal fragen
wir haben vorhin den lars eidinger schon
dazu gehört und das ist aber glaube ich
gar nicht mehr so kommt es dass man die
stücke schon gar nicht die vergessene
stücke in irgendeiner weise als
reibungsfläche interessant findet es
geht ja nicht darum dass irgendwie
klassiker getreue aufzuführen das was
ihr macht ich erinnere mich damals war
einer meiner wirklich ersten amtsjahr
kritiker ersten aufführungen den hamlet
mit mit dir als singender haben nicht
das war ja sozusagen eine eine benutzung
einer adaption der sache aber trotzdem
lebte ist vom gegenüber des textes und
das ist für dich nach wie vor doch
wichtig wenn ich das richtig verstehe
oder du brauchst ein gegenüber sonst
könntest du deine texte einfach selber
schreiben absolut also ich bin über
jeden guten dialog dankbar und wir im
theater haben das glück dass es dort
eine große große menge an wunderbaren
texten aus den jahrhunderten gibt aus
den verschiedenen jahrhunderten aber
auch aktuelle texte gegen uns wunderbare
dialoge situationen in den mund gelegt
werden in film und fernsehen wünsche ich
mich manchmal ein bisschen mehr diese
tiefe diese dialoge das futter für die
figuren die sprache der figuren gut im
film und fernseh hat man so ein bisschen
mehr möglichkeiten situation auch
nonverbal zu zeigen aber es ist schon
wichtig was sagt man wie sagt man es
und dann ist auch der rhythmus der
sprache sehr wichtig und bei shakespeare
ist natürlich der rhythmus die
musikalität schon in der sprache auch in
den deutschen übersetzungen zum beispiel
sehr zu finden und ist natürlich bietet
eine wunderbare grundlage für
musikalische auseinandersetzung damit
und ich fand es jetzt zum beispiel auch
sehr spannend die ansprache afra bin
sozusagen mit dem sex wird sozusagen zu
kreuzen oder in verbindung zu bringen
bei shakespeare ist jetzt nicht einer
der vergessenen autoren aber sondern
eigentlich eine der meistgespielten
autoren und deswegen was ganz spannend
so ein spannungsfeld aufzubauen zwischen
einer zwischen einem auch sehr
musikalischen text einer autorin zu
seinen lebzeiten mit seinem text der
eben in vielfältiger art und weise von
uns benutzt wurde oder gestaltet wurde
ja wir freuen uns jetzt gleich sehr auf
das konzert und das wird noch mal ein
wirklicher höhepunkt vielleicht das
letzte frage da du jetzt unser letzter
gast bist hier in der sendung
spielplanänderungen live vielleicht
nochmal so stellvertretend für die
vielen künstlerinnen und künstler die ja
im moment durchaus mit einem flauen
gefühl zu hause sitzen wir hören das
aktuell auf jeden fall die verlängerung
der theaterschließungen bis zu müssen
nach weihnachten debattiert wird
wahrscheinlich darüber hinaus sagt so
etwas wie im schloss mit theater bis zum
sommer ist in der diskussion mit welchem
blick vielleicht auch mit welcher
hoffnung schaust du in das nächste
theater ja ich hoffe sehr dass die
schließung der theater der orte der
kunst dass das nicht mehr so lange
anhält
auch wenn es natürlich eine hoffnung ist
die aufgrund der aktuellen lage der
pandemie einem etwas zum pessimisten
werden lässt aber ich hoffe sehr dass
die theater bald schon wieder öffnen
können und spielen können und dass man
wieder ins museum gehen kann
derart da haben wir da ist nur der heute
auch schon oft gesagt sehr gute
grundkonzepte geliefert andererseits
sind natürlich auch wir künstler im
grunde genommen bis zu einem gewissen
grad auch bereit
natürlich zum wohle der gesellschaft so
wurde der gesundheit aller natürlich
mitzuhelfen
andererseits glaube ich dass die theater
und die orte der kunst auch eine
geistige bildung haben und auch eine
sehr wichtige funktion im austausch
gerade wenn jetzt immer wieder mit angst
gespielt wird ist das glaube ich ein ort
des gemeinschaftlichen lebens was auch
manchmal ängste nehmen kann weil man
weiß man ist nicht alleine und ich
glaube das ist etwas was uns gerade
fehlt nicht nur auf der bühne nicht nur
im expressionistischen aus sich
rausgehen sondern auch indem aufnehmen
also auch die rolle des zuschauers
dieser dialog muss hoffentlich wird
hoffentlich ganz ganz bald wieder
möglich sein und wir fangen jetzt an und
hoffen so zu sagen wir hatten ja ein
projekt das mit webprojekten am
staatsschauspiel dresden
wir hoffen dass wir im dezember
wenigstens proben können dass die proben
wieder aufnehmen können und wir hoffen
ende januar die premiere dann spielen zu
können und dieses projekt ist ein
projekt was 1 1 riesen mammut projekt
ist mit sehr vielen menschen vor hinter
der bühne auf der bühne
unterschiedlichen genres und wir hoffen
dass wir das zur aufführung bringen weil
das auch letztendlich kein corona
konformes theater unbedingt ist wir
müssen natürlich auch darauf achten
nicht abgeschlossen so weit aber es ist
sowieso ein mammut wie so ein großes
feldberg auch noch mal zeigt das sind
die möglichkeiten von kunst und von
theater je nachdem wie man das auch
finden möchte aber wichtig ist solche
zeichen zu setzen und wir müssen als
schräger unsere perspektiven schaffen
wie künstlers deswegen verspreche ich
mir dass wir im nächsten jahr mit vielen
vielen wunderbaren aufführungen
projekten
die zuschauer wieder in ihren bann
ziehen und den dialog wieder breiter
führen können
und da jetzt hier auf meinen wunderbaren
holztisch dreimal für alle künstler und
dem tisch vielen dank glück und vielen
dank liebe lieber christian für diese
kollektive für diese kollektive
wünschelrute wenn man so will und es ist
nur ein ersatz aber es ist einerseits
und zwar kein zu kleiner wie sie gleich
sehen werden
film ab für ein special konzert von
christian friedel und roots of berne
[Musik]
macbeth ist reif zur ernte
und dort oben bereiten möchte schon das
messer
[Musik]
mein vater war ein höchst heiniger fürst
die könige die nicht trug weit öfter auf
den knien als auf den füßen starb jeden
tag des lebens
mich müde langsam alles sonnenlicht
mich ziehen
die alle welt in trümmern brecht
[Musik]
ich will das weib nicht mit den augen
spielen
prahlen
mit der zunge
leben es nur einwanderern schattenbild
ein armer comedian der streit und
knirscht sein ständchen auf der bühne
und dann nicht mehr vernommen
ein märchen ist
erzählt von einem blöd ling voller klang
und wut
[Musik]
das nichts bedeutet
wir sind da
[Musik]
organen tempel
dies kommt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das
ich werde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem teufel ging es zu
wenn es dem volk gefällt in zeiten der
reformation unsere welt und doch die
puritaner bringen weniger lager hervor
als ein dauernder streit über den
rechten humor urteil wie eure passionen
ein ärgernis verlangen stillen weder mut
noch mehr gedeiht so hübsch wie ein
gewissens bis den der heilige geist
jenen in die gedärme schickt die alles
verdammen
denn dieser wurm sie zwickt mit
aufgesetzten regeln wollt ihr die bühne
veredeln und unsere sinne mit stumpfer
methode versiegeln wie dreist der
republikaner für tier die regie bei
denen keck und bürgerliches politik
genie sich lustig machen über die
monarchie
letzterer sieht nur selten ein stück
außer es scheint nach alter art ihm
geglückt er schüttelt auf den gehstock
gestützt seinen kopf den lehrern und
ruft herrgott diese stücke die sind ja
verheerend als ich jung war mit welchem
geist wie verstiegen die feinsten szenen
hat man da noch geschrieben dies hier
sind nur nichtige spielen
ich bin lieber sehen was im unterhaus
heute so alles geschehen und dann kommt
er mit politik womit erkenntlich macht
welche geschäfte eher als bedeutende 8
was er auch für geist und poesie geltend
macht und die jungen jecken die sich auf
den weg zu uns machen die schreien zum
henker mit der eleganz wir wollen was
zum lachen
dem hof gefallen doch nicht solche
sachen diese stütze sind nicht zufrieden
bis das stück mit narren so grob wie sie
selbst ist gespickt
so kann man auch das eintrittsgeld
sparen und im spiegel daheim sich als
bessere esel gebaren kann krawatten
brücken gesichter aufsetzen und
grimassen ziehen nach eigenen gesetzen
schaut doch ihr schnaufen und fluchen
und stieren zu hause allein da wagen sie
es aufzuführen
woanders aber müssen sie bedachte
agieren
ach wenn doch lux und tony lee stecken
uns spielten die nur halb so echt wie
ihr sich verhielten
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der letzte
scheinwerfer ist ausgegangen jetzt ist
es wieder dunkel und der berliner
volksbühne
genauso wie in den 800 anderen theatern
in deutschland gerade die vorhänge sind
unten kein kassenhäuschen ist besetzt
die daten sind geschlossen zwei stunden
lang haben wir versucht ihnen das
theater nach hause zu bringen es von
seiner besten enthusiastischen gefühlten
seite zu zeigen
möglich war das nur weil alle die
menschen deren namen sie gleich im
abspann lesen werden mitgemacht haben
voller enthusiasmus gespielt inszeniert
diskutiert geplant gefilmt geschnitten
und großzügig gefördert haben nochmal
ein herzlicher dank an die heinz und
heide durchlüftung den tropen
beziehungsweise klett-cotta verlag und
die volksbühne berlin dank an den faz
videomacher florian hoffmann der in den
letzten monaten wirklich unglaubliches
geleistet hat dank an björn menger und
sebastian asch die hier heute auf sehr
großzügige weise technik und resi
verantwortet haben und dank nicht
zuletzt auch an sie liebe zu schauen die
zuschauer dass sie sich auf dieses
abenteuerliche experiment
spielplanänderungen
eingelassen haben ein experiment das die
nähe zwischen institutionen ausprobiert
hat in einer zeit der krise das theater
mit zeitungen zeitungen mit verlagen
verlagen mit schauspielern so eng
zusammenarbeiten wie das hier war das
ist nicht die regel das sollte auch
nicht die regel sein in normalen zeiten
ist die kritische distanz das
entscheidende aber in solchen
ausnahmesituationen für die kultur als
ganzes wo wir alle in bedrängnis geraten
sollte das eine art von herm unter dem
zeichen sein ein hoffnungsschimmer wenn
man so will der eben nicht nur im
impfstoff liegt sondern auch in
gesprochenen texten in gesängen und tanz
in diskussionen in dem das etwas
stattfindet das mit vorstellungen mit
fantasie mit gegenwelt zu tun hat das
haben wir versucht ich hoffe es hat
ihnen einigermaßen gefallen ab sofort
sind all die videos die sie hier nur in
einzelnen ausschnitten gesehen haben in
voller länge auf unserer website
verfügbar
schauen sie sich alles an sehnen sie
sich nach dem theater vergessen sie
nicht was für ein glück es ist dass wir
das schauspiel haben zu dunkel die
zeiten gerade auch sind das theater lebt
wenn sie daran glauben
in diesem sinne von wo auch immer sie
gerade zugeschaut haben haben sie
herzlichen dank für ihre zeit und ihr
interesse
ich bin simon straßen und wünsche ihnen
einen guten abend